- [Mark] All right. Tanaysha.
Tanaysha, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- San Fernando Valley,
San Fernando Valley.
My dad's from Compton.
My dad was a heroin addict,
and um, a red devil and on PCP.
By the time I got born,
I was three years old
and my dad was abusive to my mother
and had a lot of women
and he was abusive to them too.
He got killed.
I have a brother and sister-
or a sister out there
that I never seen or heard
from since they been born.
And my dad got killed by her crime, um
the baby's grandfather
for going on the property.
It's hard for me to,
to let my father go.
That's why I want to leave California.
My father took me from my
mother at the age of six.
When he got killed,
I've been with my grandmother ever since.
I never got to talk to my mother.
She's a pastor.
She live in Louisiana.
I never met her since I was born.
It was something that they took from
my family took from me
and I feel that it was selfish
and it made me suicidal
because I love my mother.
Even though I didn't know what happened.
I always want that.
My mother was something that
I didn't want nothing tooken from...
I'm gonna, it's hard for me to have things
tooken from me or
to lose things that I love so much.
- [Mark] You struggle with
depression it sounds like?
- I struggled with depression
and suicidal and voices.
I have anxiety bad now.
I have cancer now.
I have breast cancer.
I'm in pain all the time.
I've been struggling with
cocaine, crack cocaine.
Since I was 15, my
cousin adduced me to it.
I never knew what it was.
I leaned on that for my depression
so I won't feel anything
until I met a guy just recently
had me turn my life around.
I left crack alone
so I wouldn't lose him
because I lost everything in my life.
And my relationship before him.
I lost everything.
You know, constantly.
My kids. I have six kids.
- [Mark] Because of crack?
- Yes. I have six kids and
only reason why I lost my kid
because my family went behind my back.
And lied and said I wasn't around.
It wasn't for,
It wasn't for drugs.
I was living at job
court when I was young.
- [Mark] Where do you live today?
- I live on the street
right now. I lost my house
like a year ago.
I have section eight
because of my breast cancer.
- [Mark] You're in a tent?
Yeah, I'm in a tent now.
It's hard.
I cry every day because my
relationship is going sour.
And it made me go back into depression.
And now I've turned to crystal
and I don't like it and
I don't want to be on it
but it helps me to try to maintain,
but his words are good.
And, please, guys, do not get on crystal.
It's a handmade drug
and with chemicals,
if young kids are listening.
I hear a lot of voices and screams
and ghost and everything
but I was born with a gift
that I could see things
before it happened anyway,
but it's even scarier
when you can, when the
crystal - with the crystal.
The crystal make you sick,
it's hard for me to kick it
more than the crack.
I quit crack on my own
not a drug program.
Just cold turkey.
And I've been dealing with that for years.
So, uh, crystal is harder.
I get sick, I get weak.
I get nauseated and I can't let it go
because I get sick, too sick.
So I'm trying to find detox now
or some help to kick that,
whatever you do, don't
turn to get on drugs
as soon as possible
because it's a lot of people out here
with HIV and they don't
care where I live right now.
And that's called "the bottoms"
and they doing sex with women and men.
And it's scary because I woke up
with my pants half way down.
They put (mumbles), and I'm scared.
(sniffles)
I'm scared for my boyfriend.
I'm scared to put me.
It's a struggle out here on the streets
It's hard and, um
I'm depressed every day
because of the Corona is out
and it's hard to get things done faster.
I wish nothing,
I wish no drug on anyone.
Our community is full
of STDs and, and drugs.
And it's, the worst is downtown LA.
I never seen nothing
like the street I'm on
17th and close to Washington.
It's like, I'm in a devil pit
already in hell because they
do so much wrong over there.
And so much evil.
I pray every day
and I play my church music
and I keep my Bible open.
I'm just depressed and sad
and I feel so much people's pain
and the evil and it's scary
but I just want to say,
God be with me. God be with you.
And I hope the next generation make it
because kids are get messy
and everything right on that.
And the police are corrupt,
you know, everywhere.
I just hope you find that void.
That, whatever that's blocking you
and when you came up as a child,
Find it in God
cause that's the only way to go.
And I realized that
cause I keep letting his hand go and it,
God's a selfish God
So just hold on to his,
hold on to his holy hand
and pray for me too.
Thank you.
- [Mark] Tanaysha, do you feel like
the childhood that you had kind of...
- Made my life like it is? yes, yes I do.
I blame my grandmother.
- [Mark] If things were
different in your childhood,
you might've...
- Well, you know, I wish, I
try so hard to keep my kids
from feeling what I went through, but
it's like my oldest child had depression
and same, suicidal just like me,
but the rest of them are strong,
but you know, they don't have me.
They don't have me.
And that's what they,
that's what they lack and,
And if that, if my kids
are watching, I love you.
I don't love no one more than the other
because I know that Mahogany
thinks that I don't love her
'cause I don't call her.
I don't call either one of you guys.
I want you guys to live your life.
I don't want to be a stumbling block
or make promises or anything
like, cause I never did.
And I'm just want to keep that.
And you'd keep that in mind that
I'm here for you in the spirit.
And I love you.
And I'm sorry that I wasn't there.
I wasn't strong enough to go to court
and try to get my first child back,
but it hinder me
and it made me fall back
to a depression more.
- [Mark] Were you able to raise your kids?
- No
I wanted to, because I
didn't want them to go
through what I went through
without a mother.
That I show them that
I wanted to, to,
to...
you know, save them
from the world, you know,
of destruction, you know
like it is, you know what I mean?
I wanted to protect them for
the pain that I feel today
but I couldn't, I couldn't, you know.
I didn't know how.
- [Mark] Have you ever been treated
for your depression at all?
- [Tanaysha] Yes, I have.
I take psych meds
- [Mark] You do?
- [Tanaysha] and they work
to a certain extent, you know
when I miss a day or two
like, you can't do that
you have to stay constantly
on your medication.
And by the Corona being out
it was hard for me to get medication.
It just like, God, I let God hand go.
I let the meds go.
You know?
And you know, cause the pain is crucial
that I have, I have several knots
and they big as a tennis ball
and I can barely do anything.
I can barely have three
pounds on my elbow.
One elbow.
I have bad knees.
My, I'm in pain all the time.
I can't get out of bed.
My bladder is where I
can't feel I got to pee.
I'm losing, uh, you know,
appetite constantly
because of my anxiety and
my depression on, together.
And by me losing my cousin recently
and my baby dad within a year,
I lost every - four people.
And that, the devil's busy.
You know, but I'm still praying.
I'm holding on.
But sometimes I feel like
I wanna hurt somebody.
The people that's hurting
other people, you know
they don't deserve it.
But I be feeling that and
I be trying, trying so
hard not to act on it
and call for help.
And I won't have my
boyfriend no more and...
He was my best friend before
I- he was my boyfriend
I wouldn't be with him until
I had to figure it out,
is he meant for me?
- [Mark] And you've been on
the street for how many years?
- Yes.
- [Mark] How many years?
Well, I've been on the
streets for a long time.
All my life, really.
My kids was all raised
in one house where my
auntie and she was abusive
to certain kids of them, like one or two.
And um,
One of them got tooken from her and
one of my kids got molested
before she died, by her husband.
And I'm fighting with that too, you know?
Cause I know what my
daughter went through.
I have been molested when I was young.
Also I got raped for something I didn't do
(mumbles) stole some crack
cocaine for some dope dealer.
And they gang raped me
and beat me with guns.
I laid in my own puddle of blood.
For my boyfriend, for five (mumbles)
(crying)
I tried to kill myself at 12
and I'll be feeling like that lately.
Sometime I feel down.
I wasn't meant to be here
for, to be happy, you know?
I don't want it.
I don't want to leave
my kids on this earth.
I wish I never had kids
because I don't mean
like, I don't love them
but this world is real bad
and it felt like I'm in hell already.
Every day I'm fighting.
I'm fighting a battle to stay
alive because of the Corona.
Cause I can get it
and I can die instantly with the cancer.
So I had to stay inside my tent every day.
24 hours at least, almost.
- [Mark] What was the
best time of your life?
- Having my baby come out.
My kids.
That was it.
And my boyfriend, the new one
I have, but now it went bad
because where we at
it's like the devil pit
like I got said,
and it's like, I don't
know where he'll be anymore
but it's always that little
bit of smile come out of him
that remind me who he really is.
So I holds on tight because
I don't want leave him there.
And something's telling
me this just to hold on.
But I can't because he's
having sex with every female.
And I don't want him to
fall into a trap with everybody else.
We lost out here.
- [Mark] What's, what's
the most important lesson
you've learned from being on
the street all these years?
- Not to let God's hand go.
Because without him
there's nothing impossible.
Not being capable of that happening
without his blessings
because God's a selfish God,
I know a lot of people
don't believe in God
but it's always a chance,
you know,
to change is good.
Change is good.
It's always worth the try.
Never give up.
You know?
There must be some failure.
I just say always give yourself a chance.
You know?
Everybody's not bad
and you got the good and you got the bad.
You have to go through life
to find out certain things.
I would take the risk I had like this,
Life like this.
Like you said "Life wait for no one."
And when you on drugs, you don't exist.
- [Mark] All right, Tanisha.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you. Thank
you for talking to me.
- Welcome. Thank you. Welcome.
- [Tanaysha] Good luck
with, with everything.
(sniffles)